our next speaker is the second person to
speak for the college in recent months
who helped to lead the brexit charge in
britain many of you here were on campus
in February of this year when Nigel
Faraj former UK Independence Party
leaders spoke at the college's Winston
Churchill conference so we're delighted
to have with us tonight another one of
those freedom-loving rabble rousers a
writer and journalist Daniel Hannan has
spent the past 17 years as a member of
the European Parliament where he devoted
much of his time to campaigning to
abolish his own job I'm happy to report
that as of June 23rd 2016 he succeeded
and he's the author of several books
including the bestseller inventing
freedom how the english-speaking peoples
made the modern world his latest book is
what next how to get the best from
brexit and we're delighted he could be
with us once again please welcome Daniel
Hannan
[Applause]
the Tim thank you very much Mary thank
you for your kind words later gentleman
thank you all for coming and it's such a
pleasure to be able to stand here as a
citizen of a soon-to-be independent
country among lovers of independence
here days in fact the anniversary of the
first shots being fired at Lexington and
Concord in 1775 19th of April so
independence is very much on my mind as
I know it is on yours you know the the
fact that so often glossed over when we
talk about the Hillsdale day it doesn't
take money independence in the exact
literal sense of financial self-reliance
is part of a wider concept independence
as my deal of self-reliance something
that we try and transmit to people the
idea that ultimately we are answerable
for our own actions and that we
shouldn't as a first resort turn to the
state for solutions the real genius of
what he'll fail achieves is based on the
realization that the greatest treasure
in any country is its people and that
being a nation when Larry Jo said that
the nation is not an artificial contract
I'll tell you why it's not not official
construct the thing that makes a nation
is an understanding that our children
are not just a random set of individuals
born to a different random set of
individuals but they are inheritors of a
great tradition being Americans means
that you have been privileged to inherit
freedoms from your parents and that that
imposes on you the obligation to pass
those freedoms intact to the next
generation and in transmitting those
values he'll fail does the greatest work
imaginable so in this year of
anniversaries thank you to all of you
whatever you do to support it whether
you do it financially whether you do it
in any way thank you all of you from
making that contribution
I want to talk tonight about what it is
that we're transmitting what it is that
is special in Western civilization and
particularly in this extraordinary
country and let's start with today's
anniversary of 1775 you might find it an
odd thing that I come here as a
patriotic British politician and in the
praises of the militiamen at Lexington
and Concord after all its nowadays
portrayed is a great national struggle
if you go to the site of the battle the
tour guides will say well the British
were over here the Americans were over
here of course no one at the time would
have recognized those terms at all it
would have been a quite extraordinary
way of describing it now we're all
taught the soil Americans used to be
taught the story where education was
still widespread about Paul Revere
thundering through the little townships
of eastern Massachusetts and shouting
the British are coming I think about
that story for about ten seconds and you
will spot a fairly major flaw in it
right the entire population of
Massachusetts at that time had never
thought of itself as anything except
British it would have been an extremely
odd thing had he actually I mean I know
they do some strange things in
Massachusetts I know they have some very
odd opinions including by the way
wanting to ban the private possession of
firearms in Lexington right go figure
but but even in Massachusetts I think it
would be considered fairly eccentric to
shout the British are coming in a
completely British population what he
actually said with the regulars are out
or in one version the Redcoats are out
but what is it in our shared
traditionally I think that the the
militiamen who gathered to oppose the
regulars they didn't see themselves as
revolutionaries I think they thought of
themselves as conservatives in their
minds they were defending the freedom
that they assumed they had been born
with an Englishman in their minds the
innovations were coming from a German
King and a foreign court and that's why
I think all english-speaking peoples
have a stake
in the success and prosperity of this
great Republic in order to describe what
it is that makes our tradition unique
and elevated and Noble and in deference
to the presence of dr. Arnn who is the
world's greatest Churchill scholar let
me take you back to August of 1941 to
the day that Franklin Roosevelt made the
longest walk of his presidency in a way
that would be unimaginable today the
American media at that time conspired to
hive the facts of SDR of FDR's polio
from the electorate every photograph
showed him either standing unaided or
seated but that day is a 10th of August
he decided that he was literally going
to rise to the occasion he was on the
ship HMS Prince of Wales rode off
Newfoundland and he was going to meet
Winston Churchill he defied the advice
of all of his officials who said don't
try and walk across a deck that might
pitch and roll very slowly
leaning heavily on his cave supported on
one side by his son and on the other by
a naval officer who made his way across
the deck as the band struck up the Stars
and Stripes forever and what followed
was the most perfect and vivid
demonstration of what it is that makes
the tradition of the english-speaking
peoples it happened to be a Sunday
morning and so the crews of the two
ships USS Augusta which had brought
Roosevelt and HMS Prince of Wales were
marshaled for a joint religious service
Churchill had chosen every detail
personally and meticulous thankful the
hymns that were going to be sung down to
the reading that the chaplain was to
give
came from Joshua one as I was with Moses
so will I be with I will not fail thee
nor forsake thee be strong and of good
courage and utter words exultant Li
Churchill burst out the same language
the same hymns the same ideals and when
she said the same ideals he wasn't
making some bland generalization about
being the good guys think of the world
as it stood in 1941 the entire Eurasian
landmass from Lisbon to Vladivostok was
under one form or another of
authoritarianism freedom was beaten back
to its core english-speaking heartland -
no it's the easiest thing in the world
to take things for granted
to become blasé about what we've grown
up with but almost everything that we
now take for granted as part of being a
modern liberal open comfortable society
was something that owed its rise to the
victory of the english-speaking peoples
we take the granted regular elections
and uncensored newspapers and equality
between men and women and jury trials
and habeas corpus
we call them universal values just
imagine that the Cold War had ended
differently well just imagine that the
Second World War had ended differently
there'd be nothing Universal about from
them the reality is that all of those
precepts were overwhelmingly developed
in the language in which you are
listening to my words and that is the
peculiar genius of the english-speaking
peoples and that is where he'll fail and
all of us have an obligation to keep
alive what makes us who we are and it
was as a people conscious of who we are
conscious of what our fathers had done
that my countrymen
into defied all the official advice
disregarded all the hectoring and the
bullying and the threat and chose to be
once again
a self-governing nation hiring and
firing its own lawmakers living under
its own statutes
[Applause]
you know there's a phrase against all
the odds is a very overused one in
politics but on this occasion against
all the odds wall that is literally a
site translated into probabilities that
bookies odds on the day of the vote
where eighteen percent believe
eighty-two percent four remain
journalist were casting around for
cliches it was David versus Goliath you
know David had it easy compared to us
right
I mean Goliath we know was a big guy
right six cubits and a span and he had a
big Eddy helmet in his brass coat
weighed five thousand shekels and the
part of his sphere was as a Weaver's
loom and its head was six hundred
shekels of iron but he was just one guy
you want something more equivalent to
what happened in our exit referendum
imagine the Goliath said hey I don't
like to look at that little shepherd boy
but he sent back the gap for
reinforcements but he got a proper troop
of Philistine spearmen before behind
him--as they'd all rushed a little David
or mass and then boom boom boom one
after another they gone down slingshot
to forage that would have been a little
bit closer to what it was that we were
taking on every party leader every
broadcaster every big corporation every
think tank and and internationally
funded bureaucracy the whole of the
establishment in arms one of my
constituents put it beautifully she said
you know this is the working classes
against the smirking classes now the
British class system is so convoluted
that very few of us understand it
ourselves let alone being able to
explain it to friends in other countries
but I think most Americans will have a
sense of what it was she was getting at
and on the day that people threw off the
system as a horse
shakes off flies and you know what they
were right they were right to disregard
all the official advice all of the
things that we were told during the
campaign would follow as consequences of
a leaflet had conspicuously failed to
materialise the IMF today for the third
time upgraded its growth forecasts
having told us during the campaign that
it would be calamitous
if we voted to leave we were told that
there would be a technical recession in
2016 thanks
we grew faster in the six months after
the vote than we had in the six months
before and finished 2016 as the most
successful major economy in the world we
were told that if we voted leave but
unemployment would rise by 250,000 over
the next two years well when nine months
into that and it's so far fallen by
60,000 we were told that if we voted
leave the stock exchange would collapse
we weren't told that that would be the
Italian stock exchange and the British
stocks would be the best performing in
Europe and we disregarded you know one
of the things that happened during the
campaign was David Cameron of course
understandably called in help from every
foreign leader who owes him a favor
including Barack Obama and Barack Obama
came in he said he's in his best sort of
school mastery manner you know he's not
a man who likes to be crossed in any way
he said you need to understand that if
you vote to leave you are going to be
back of the line for any trade deal with
the United States only he considerately
translated it into the British
vernacular and said back of the queue
those of you like penny who have lived
in the UK and indeed like dr. Arnn who
studied Winston Churchill there will
know that you know queues are a big deal
so this is this is a this is an
important cultural reference for him and
you know and I have trade it did make a
difference it made a difference because
we're before opinion polls published the
following week and all of them showed a
massive swing to vote leave and
I made I may be the only speaker ever to
have had the chance to say this at a
hill sale event but thank you for
October because you may have been the
guy who made the difference but you know
I'll tell you why why it was the people
reacted as they did I'll be honest it's
not because there's any animus against
Barack Obama it was that we knew in our
bones that he was urging on us a policy
that no American would countenance I
suppose that I were to come here as a
British politician and say okay guys
here's the plan for what you should do
next we want you to form a soupcon
national plan American Union okay let's
have a Pan American Parliament in I'm
not Caracas that will have the power to
override your national laws and let's
have a Supreme Court in Managua that can
strike down acts of your Congress why
don't we throw in while we're at it a
central banking Lima that will
administer your new currency the
pan-american peso I'm I'm guessing that
the reaction of most of you would be
buzz off
I suspect some of you would use a
stronger word than buzz and you'd be
right - because independence the ability
to hire and fire your rulers the sublime
idea that laws should not be passed nor
taxes raised except by those who are
answerable to the rest of us is the most
precious thing a nation can have and so
when people heard barackobama urging us
to merge our national identity in with
other countries we politely but firmly
declined his advice and we were right
this is a great thing one of the things
that dr. Ahn talks about he mentioned
again tonight but the mismatch between
the bureaucracy and everybody else if
you really want to understand what
happened in June in our brexit
referendum I can do no better than offer
Edmund Burke's diagnosis in 1791 he said
because half a dozen Grasshoppers
concealed beneath the theurn make the
field ring with their unfortunate cheek
of thousands of great casual take their
repose in the shade of the British oak
and chew the cud in silence pray do not
imagine that those who make all the
noise are the only inhabitants of the
field well we discovered on the 24th of
June that not only were the oxen more
numerous than the crickets but they were
right of course the crickets are still
shrieking in outrage and never more
loudly than today because they thought
they could bring the whole process back
into Parliament and for the last nine
months they've been saying all to reason
they have no mandates or breaks it she
doesn't even have a mandate to be Prime
Minister nobody elected her so the
moment she says okay let's have a
mandate oh no but this is terrible
there's a the Labour guys the latest
spokesman on brexit said this is a coup
right this is an unusual way to describe
Parliament dissolving itself and asking
for a new mandate from the people it's a
coup meaning of course what he means by
that is it's been taken out of the hands
of
hoppers that people have made their rude
entry back into the field and that I
tell you water the one thing the one
thing I've learned is that people are
wiser than their leader and the reason
I'm optimistic both about my country and
about yours is that the people are now
back in charge now here's the thing I
want to make I want to say one other
thing about the restaurant which is is
there anyone here from Indiana anybody
here tonight from any I know you've come
from all over
one very oh so it's probably about in
proportion to the population of Indiana
isn't it so well that one it's going to
have to be my proxy here when I say that
for the rest of my life whose ears in
general and Mike Pence in particular are
always going to have a special place in
my heart I'll tell you why a week after
that Barack Obama back at the Q thing
the state of Indiana took out
advertisements in UK newspapers which
said cousins however you vote you're
always at the front of the business
queue in Indiana and then it then went
on to list you know British Airways and
British Aerospace and Tate & Lyle and
all of the UK companies in Indiana now
at that time nobody thought we were
going to win and it's one of those
moments where you really learn who your
friends are and that's why I'm so
pleased about the change in tone just
today we had the Speaker of Congress
Paul Ryan in London calling for an
immediate move to a bilateral free trade
agreement you know Indiana is not alone
in being able to lift all of those UK
companies virtually every state in the
Union could come up with a similar roll
call and so could every region of the UK
if it were the other way around
Britain is the biggest investor here the
u.s. is the biggest investor in Britain
a million bricks every day turn out to
work for American owned companies a
million Americans every day clock in to
work for British owned companies the
only things that so far has not followed
has been the trade because the trade has
been controlled by Brussels not London
and that can now shake
we can form the most obvious common
market based as it is on a common
language and law common habit in history
common customs and kinship but here's
the thing we first need to win the
argument for free trade being desirable
and at the moment I'm not sure we are
winning that great paradox of our age
the human race has never been materially
better often now you can measure it in
any way you like literacy longevity
calorie intake female education height
here any way you like right there's
never been a better time to be alive as
recently as 1990 38% of human beings
lived in extreme poverty defined by the
UN as an income of $1 a day or less now
it's 8% we can realistically look
forward to the complete elimination of
that kind of squalor I think if the
change is just while I've been alive I
was born in 1971 in 1971 it took the
average American more than a month on
average wages to be able to afford a
color TV set now it's less than two days
in 1971 a stationary car emitted more
pollution than a car moving at full
speed today in 1971 fewer and a half or
girls worldwide completed primary
education now it's more than 90% and yet
in almost every advanced country in fact
all over the world well-meaning
idealistic people are marching against
trade deals picketing g20 meetings
occupying stock exchanges thinking that
in doing so they are standing up for the
poor against the big corporates whereas
in reality they're doing exactly the
opposite nobody gains more from
distortions and tariffs and quotas than
the big multinationals nobody gains more
from their lifting than the poorest
people on earth the miracle that we've
seen in my life
has been driven by previously closed
economies entering the global market
system she's going to be back to the
mission of Hillsdale so what I'm saying
is a counterintuitive and difficult idea
but just think at the extent as the
miracle that has been achieved in this
country and in other countries based on
property and free exchange posited
history of the human race ten thousand
years ago we discovered farm right
amazing discovery that you put seeds in
the ground and crops come up it took
about five minutes for somebody to make
the next discovery which is it's easier
to steal somebody else's crops than to
spend all year tending to my own and and
about five minutes after that the really
lethal breakthrough which is the best
ratio of effort to outcome is not to go
round marauding myself but to regularize
that predation through tithes and tolls
and taxes and thus was agrarian
civilization born in tyranny and for
most of the last ten thousand years that
was the story of the human race
oppression serfdom caste slavery squalor
what we call history was truly the
history of the one percent of the one
percent while everybody else bent their
backs dawn-to-dusk in the fields and
then the miracle came and it happened in
the english language the extraordinary
idea that you could elevate the rules
above the ruler the idea that we were
autonomous individuals free to contract
deals one with another on an
issue-by-issue basis without having all
of our relations mediated by caste and
birth and tradition and shift from
status to contract and on the back of it
came ultimately the little miracle in
the old courthouse in philadelphia i say
that mines of the signatories they were
drawing on an old tradition they didn't
think they were inventing anything they
looked back through the English
revolution the English Civil War back
through the Great Charter back to the
right of anglo-saxon common-law but a
one thing that they knew that
civilization was based on was the rule
of law and private property that's the
peculiar genius of the english-speaking
peoples but it's based on the idea of
ownership and free exchange it's based
on the idea that what we do with our
goods and possessions is up to us and
not up to the government and that idea
is under fire under fire intellectually
here and in my country and everywhere
else I was amazed you know I spent part
of the the last presidential election
here I was amazed watching both
candidates attacking each other for
shopping abroad is there so kind of a
bad thing to buy stuff more cheaply and
concentrate on what you do well free
trade is under fire and it's always on
apparently superficially plausible
grounds well we're in favor of free
trade in principle but we need to
nurture some infant industry or we need
to have self-reliance in its strategic
area I'll tell you why all of those
arguments are specious you think of it
like this why in wartime do we blockade
enemy belligerents what is it we're
trying to achieve when we cut off a
country the we're fighting against we're
trying to make the poorer we're trying
to disrupt their supply no can we all
agree that we're not doing it to nurture
their infant industries we're not trying
to do them a favor by making them more
self-sufficient in food or energy we're
not going to build them up so they can
be more competitive in world markets
every argument for tariffs and
distortions ends up being an argument
for inflicting on yourself in peacetime
what an enemy power does to you in
wartime the difficulty we have I'll be
frank about this I've been an elected
representative now for 18 years what I'm
saying is counterintuitive it is a
literally counterintuitive we have some
together a brain we haven't evolved
instinct that tells us that we want to
provide against famine we want to hoard
food we want to be self-reliant the idea
of being dependent on other people may
be the basis of civilization but it's
running up against the million years of
evolution ultimately how do you win this
argument you win it by doing it and
showing that it works and if you look at
the countries in the world that have
opened their markets the Singapore's the
New Zealand for Hong Kong's company ever
wants to go back when finger tour became
independent 1960 income the heads there
was slightly less than half of what it
was in the UK now it's nearly twice how
did that happen in a country without any
natural resources at all computer have
to import even its drinking water it's
in turn from a tropical mosquito
infested swamp into one of the most
extraordinary city-states in the world
because it removed all barriers to trade
simple as that everything else followed
now we have an opportunity now your
country in mind to achieve something
extraordinary to have a trading
relationship based around mutual
recognition of products and free
competition getting away from all the
cartels and the corporatism that we saw
creeping in to the Obama
administration's trade talks getting rid
of all the attempts to impose common
standards and raise barriers against
smaller rivals simple deal that says you
know what if this is legal in your
country it's legal in ours and vice
versa
somebody can practice on Wall Street he
can practice in the City of London
someone can sell insurance in Britain he
can sell it here the drug is approved by
the FDA that's good enough for us if we
did that we would boost our economies by
billions and the only losers would be
the cartel politicians the lobbyists and
the big corporates who use regulation as
a way of disadvantaging their rivals if
we can make that work
I hope it will underpin a great new age
of British American global leadership
I began by I began by mentioning the
coincidence of the day I did a lot a lot
of a lot of as Tim said a lot of
anniversaries around it's not just the
anniversary of Lexington Lexington and
Concord today is exactly the 19th of
April 1817 was when David Ricardo
published the theory of comparative
advantage on which all three trade rests
if your country and mind can make a
reality of it we will have done the
human race some service it wouldn't be
anything very radical is in your
tradition and in house our mission was
to elevate and ennoble the species by
moving the obstacles by shifting the
rocks and letting the grass grow it
wasn't long after Lexington and Concord
that our countries became allies and
friends the first US ambassador to the
quarters and James following
independence was John Adams the future
president and when he was presented to
the king eagle it could have been a
pretty awkward meeting as you can
imagine but he made a very handsome and
effecting speech and he ended by saying
Your Majesty I should have come myself
the happiest of men if I could restore
the old good nature and old good humor
between peoples who though separated by
an ocean and living under different
governments have yet the same language
kindred religion and shared blood well
times have moved on a little bit we no
longer have exactly shared blood both of
our countries have been altered by
demographic change but I think we have
something much more important we have
the kindred of the mind we have a shared
outlook and that gives us a stake in
your success and that's why my friends I
am so optimistic now when I look at the
likely future of the United States I see
Congress buzzing with ideas of things
that haven't been done for decades but
it can now be achieved return of power
from Washington to the
State shifting power from the unelected
federal bureaucrat to the elected local
representative a reduction in tax rates
particularly corporate tax rates to a
level that the rest of the
industrialized world would regard as
kind of normal
I can see eventually I think also a
repeal of Obamacare which has been a
cage around your economy even how about
this judges who will rule on the basis
of what the law says rather than on the
basis of what they think it ought to say
there is every reason to be optimistic
about the future of this country and I
want you to know this we will be
alongside you although we may not all
still have kindred blood we do have
kindred beliefs we sing the same songs
we kneel at the same altars we cleave to
the creed of freedom hold fast to that
freedom pass it on securely
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
thank you we now have time for some
questions Daniel Hannan has graciously
agreed to take some questions from the
audience we have some students with
microphones we just ask that you wait
for the microphone to come to you to ask
your question and the students will find
you so with that the floor is open yes
most of the in regard to the European
Union wasn't the Constitution itself an
exercise in independent states giving up
their freedoms for a larger government
for the common good yeah it's a really
interesting exercise to compare your
Constitution to the constitution of the
European Union which is now called the
Lisbon Treaty your constitution is 7,200
words including all the amendments the
--use is more than 175,000 words yours
is mainly about the dispersal of power
drawing the border between state and
federal authority and so on he uses
mainly about the concentration of power
it keeps enumerated more and more powers
for on everything from the status of the
disableds of space exploration I mean
there is a boundless you know there was
a debate at the time why is the no
mention of Europe's judeo-christian
heritage well yeah I think it's all
there in the Babel story when you have
authors with this level of presumption
there's no room for the almighty in a
document like that I mean I suspect
he'll be able to look after himself but
it's the document that I was worried
about your your Declaration of
Independence promises life liberty the
pursuit of happiness ye use equivalent
which is called the Charter of
Fundamental Rights and Freedoms
guarantees our right to strike action
free health care and affordable housing
you see the difference in approach here
like me that the categorical difference
in attitude to state power and I think
the real clincher is this your
Constitution eventually came into effect
following ratification by the 13 Member
State
what by eleven of them I think curves of
Rhode Island and North Carolina came
into line of it later the EU
Constitution was rejected in referendum
in France in the Netherlands and in
Ireland and was then imposed anyway
because they've never been concerned
about democracy they regard their
ideology as being too important to be
left to the ballot box they think it
Trump's the rule of law freedom and the
will of the people and ultimately that
was the system that Britain voted to
leave right see I really want to stress
this we're not turning our backs on our
allies in Europe during the campaign a
decision was made to deploy British
forces to defend Poland in Estonia that
deployment has now been made no one has
criticized it it's a completely
uncontroversial thing the west standing
by our friends in Europe we have a
continuing interest an immediate stake
in the success of our European neighbors
because prosperous neighbors make good
customers and because these are old
friends of ours so we were not voting
against Europe what we were voting
against was a remote self-serving
bureaucracy that admits no impediment to
its ambitions that is utterly at odds
with your tradition utterly at odds with
ours we will be a free independent
people interested and engaged in the
affairs of every continent including
Europe but living once again under our
own laws
I'm going to make a couple of statements
and I'd like you to comment two things
from personal experience I'm a nurse we
have had a lead problem in our country
in the past the u.s. stopped making lead
products in our country guess what we I
want to let me clarify this
I'm not criticizing China people I'm
criticizing stuff that comes from China
please I know many Chinese have died for
their freedom
I remember Tiananmen Square I remember
when the Chinese do you know if anybody
remembers this in the recent history
about two chinese people that try to
come to this country about nailing
themselves here and they suffocated so
please do not think I'm going after
China personally we had blood paint
in our country we cannot manufacture LED
containing products with some of the way
the regulations are we let lead products
come into our country again that come
from China okay I can comment I have
been a boat owner my boat was my home
for a period of five years did not know
there was a difference between American
steel and steel made from China I bought
something not knowing that the Chinese
piece of steel
what's up standard it could have taken
my home out if I have been not on the
dock did not know it was substandard
never had a problem with American steel
okay I think I get I get where you're
coming from and of course this is this
is this issue will arise even in the US
UK talks right there are people in my
constituency who say it's all but I
don't want the hormone treated beef that
they have in the US or the current
obsession is the chlorinated chicken
apparently you treat chicken with
chlorine or something at there I had
this actually at a meeting not long ago
the lady asked a very similar question
to yours but from a from our point of
view and maybe if you if you think about
this coming from another country but
directed against American products
you'll you'll see what's wrong with it
she said I'm I don't want to be eating
this chlorinated chicken and I thought
well you know okay madam I could explain
that no one's going to force you to
but if I'm explaining that I'm losing
the argument so instead I just this was
an excellent part of my constituency
part of sorry so I just said okay
everybody put up your hand if you've
been to the US or it 100 percent of
people know okay keep your hand up if
you had any chicken while you were there
of course it's still almost 100 percent
right
people are very easily scared when
something new is proposed but remember
that all of the common law defenses that
a consumer has will still be in force
here like if somebody is guilty of miss
Celie or of tort or of producing
something that is deleterious to public
health that is covered under your
existing legal system what we're talking
about is lifting restrictions that are
imposed by a producer here in order to
keep out a competitor from overseas now
this has happened with Chinese deal it's
happened in the US with Chinese deal in
2009 Barack Obama in response to
pressure from the United Steelworkers
imposed tariffs on wheels wheels made of
steel from China tariffs they went up in
stages to 35% okay the cost of this
policy was 1.1 billion dollars
did it save any jobs like yes it's saved
1200 jobs among US Steel Workers jobs
that were paid an average of $40,000
okay so for an outlay of 1.1 billion
dollars there was a saving equivalent to
48 million dollars it was much worse
than that because people were having to
spend much more money on buying these
wheels from Indonesia oh well they had
less money to spend on everything else
and as a result of not being able to
spend money on other products 3,700 jobs
were lost across the rest of the economy
some of them almost certainly held by
members of the United Steelworkers why
does that happen
it's what the French economist bat-eared
calls the visible and the invisible or
the seen and the unseen in fact I'll
summarize the problem as a politician
the problem with free trade can be
summarized in four
were dispersed gains concentrated losses
you buy the cheapest Chinese steel maybe
some of it is produced at the low-cost
pipe maybe they're stupid enough to be
subsidizing you right a gift from the
Chinese taxpayer to the US consumer what
happens what happens is that almost
everyone in the US is a little bit
better off every car makers suddenly
gains in productivity without having to
lift a finger
more people get employed prices for they
then have more to spend that creates
even more jobs it's a great story for
almost everyone under the end of the
year I guarantee you not a single
American is going to say hey I'm 87
dollars a year better off I going to
vote for the guy who signed that deal
with China because the gains are just
first and impalpable whereas the newly
unemployed guy in Pennsylvania or
wherever he knows exactly whom to blame
and evokes accordingly this is why it
doesn't happen this is why there was
this concentration on protecting jobs in
what happened to be swing states
whatever the cost to the wider economy
sugar in this country is twice world
prices twice why because Florida is a
swing state frankly and the the sugar
producers in that state lobby both
parties and give a lot of money to both
of them result candy makers
confectioner's have started moving
abroad either to Canada or to Mexico of
course they have because the sugar is so
much cheaper there for every job says if
we have to use that word on the sugar
plantation in Florida 16 jobs are lost
in food processing in the rest of the
country so why do politicians in both
parties keep the quotas and the terrace
in place dispersed gains concentrated
losses it's the same basic problem right
those 16 people those 16 jobs that would
come back into existence if the if the
prices fell they don't know who they are
those jobs exist only in the subjunctive
where is the guy on the plantation in
Florida he knows exactly whom to vote
for and this is why it doesn't happen
but you know Oliver it's not a good
enough reason and
when you've made that change as a New
Zealand or son of Australia is doing now
yeah this protest at the time but within
a few years nobody ever wants to go back
because they see the real benefit of
free trade which is that it benefits the
poorest people the most the things are
falling the cost of living and the big
winners other people who had to spend
the highest percentage where their
incomes on binary commodities so free
trade is the ultimate instrument of
poverty alleviation of conflict
resolution and a social justice time for
one more
yep couple more please mr. Hannon thank
you for coming this evening your remarks
were deeply inspiring brilliant
questions thank you time for one more an
eloquent and men like you cause us to
have renewed faith in our Constitution
and in the cause of Western civilization
so I hope you will strongly consider
running for Parliament and joining
Theresa Mays cabinet thank
on the subject of the Prime Minister
she was actually opposed to brexit I
believes she obviously has taken a
different path in following the lead of
of the country so my question I been
often compared to the Iron Lady first
came to power in 1979 so like my
question is how do you compare her to
Margaret Thatcher who has a statue at
Hillsdale College and what do you see as
the future of the Conservative Party in
Great Britain thank you well you're
right Teresa may opposed brexit but she
behaved as a proper Democrat and she
realized that if you're going to
implement the will of the people but the
worst of all worlds is to implement it
sulkily or half-heartedly
if you're going to do this thing you do
it properly in such a way as to maximise
the advantages to us and to our European
allies and I hope our allies further
afield it's I suppose an inevitable
comparison we're not so rich in female
conservative prime ministers that people
can pick a lot of other examples I've
got to say by the way I'm very proud of
the fact that both Margaret Thatcher and
Theresa May were elected in their own
right rather than in the Banana Republic
fashion of being married to some
previous guy right I mean that was that
struck me as a
but the real difference is this Margaret
Thatcher was elected at a very testing
time for us your president will remember
it he was in the UK at the time it was
it was one of our lowest in fact I would
argue that the 70s were our lowest
moment as a NASA nation we'd run out of
money we had constant strikes we had
rampant trade union as we were we even
got to the point of of having to be
bailed out by the IMS she began
therefore with very few advantages and
by sheer force of will and a refusal to
accept that a great country would
retreat forever
she turned things around ELISA Mae
begins from a much stronger position
Margaret Thatcher never really had her
party behind her from the beginning to
the end
Tereza May I think has a stronger
position than any conservative leader I
can think of since well since church
alleges height she inherits a growing
economy and she's on the threshold of
being able to reorient our policy away
from a declining European trade bloc
towards the bits of the world that are
growing which is to say the whole of the
world outside Europe right and so I
think her position is is therefore by
far the more enviable
because that doesn't necessarily make
you a better or a worse regarded leader
now I think some of the the greatest
u.s. leaders are overlooked because they
happened not to live in especially
testing times had the circumstances been
different we might think of Grover
Cleveland or of a Calvin Coolidge as
Titanic presidents but in a way
fortunately for them they were never put
to the test in that way and I think the
way things are working out that we are
looking forward to a smooth transition
out of the European Union and amical
amicable cordial brexit leading I hope
to a renewal of our alliance with the
other free english-speaking peoples this
will be our final question okay hi
I have a question with regards to
breakfast with why the bankers of the EU
feel or felt that they could actually
find the UK for pulling out I don't
understand that yeah it just took the
question kind of explains why we left
right I mean this is what an
extraordinary extraordinary attitude I
mean the bankers generally and the
bureaucrats loved and loved the EU and
they love it and diplomats and
politicians they all love it because
they get to Brussels and they perceive a
system that was designed by and for
people like that a racket that keeps the
general electorate out of the picture
and that concentrates hands concentrate
power in the hands of officials who are
immune to public in so they really they
really take it very bad Obama like they
react very badly to being gainsaid and
especially when our game said by the
majority of the people you know and so I
think it is at the back of their minds
this will come to our senses if they
offer us bad enough terms that we will
somehow shake off the spell and meekly
come back and apologize which i think is
a bad miss reading of our history and a
bad miss reading of our character but
it's a very revealing policy because
think about this if the European Union
is saying we need to deter you from
leaving
we need to inflict a punishment beating
on anyone who tries to leave then it's
not a club of nations at all it's a
protection racket and what's going to be
the attitude of the ones who are still
inside are they going to say oh well it
worked out and we'd better stay where
they can say we're hang on this isn't
what we find out what you're now saying
that every country would be better off
if they left except insofar as you try
and inflict fines and earn and trade
barriers on it but we want no part of
this ultimately I don't think that's
gonna happen I have a higher opinion of
our European allies than that although
there are definitely people in the
European Commission and the European
Parliament
one that to happen and they were quite
explicit about it in the 27 national
capitals and altogether more realistic
attitude prevails and I think they are
looking forward as we are to the moment
when we stop being such a bad neighbor
sorry sobbing such a bad tenant and
become instead a good neighbor
[Applause]